welcome to welcome weekend 2021  got some exciting games and also ram  seahawks right pat  pat no we talked about this please never  let me play wild card we can  [Music]  [Applause]  josh allen keeps going all in every hand  wait if i win i'd get more money  i'm gonna try to beat you wow the  disrespect sick tom can lamar finally  win when the lights are bright  i will destroy this narrative hopefully  years of hard work leading up to this  moment why the [ __ ] am i being slimed  saints bears brought us back to rhythm  hatch junior  all right let's check out on these  clowns all in moving on taylor heineken  what a story and baker gets to play  without a coach lucky bastard  oh look they're already up this is phil  you're 39 years old  this is fluffing okay i did the  unthinkable i beat washington i'm the  better running back wait no  wow we were undefeated the first 11  hands tune in next week when i get to  play the rams  [Music]  coach cody parkey  you look well you son of a